each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available today we have the privilege of
having Rod Van Meter here with us uh he
is a professor at Ko University he's
been visiting MSR all week and today
he's going to talk about internet scale
Quantum repeater networks so Rod thanks
so I have a tendency to kind of wander
around as I talk um so I will be Here
There and Everywhere um so we've had a
very good week here at uh Microsoft
research I think it's been uh a good
learning experience for all of us and I
hope you guys have gotten some something
out of it as well um we've talked mostly
this week about error correction
architecture and compilers uh so I want
to kind of end the week on a little bit
of a different topic um the other big
area that I've been funded to do
research on for the last four years five
years is um Quantum repeater networks
and in particular my interest my
background being as a systems person
rather than a a Quantum physicist is in
how we're actually going to scale these
things up so
uh between the theorists at the top and
the experimentalists at the bottom
there's this this huge gap and the stuff
that's in the middle is architecture and
engineering and that's the stuff that
that the uh the physicists tended to
sort of uh you know write as uh you know
a Lemma in their in their in their
papers somebody will take care of this
right well I'm the guy who wants to take
care of this so we've got a bunch of
interesting stuff I think results from
various things um the
general concept I want to talk about the
overall architecture I want to talk
about today is a thing we call recursive
Quantum repeater networks I'll give you
sort of the preview of it U if you've
got a large network
of where each of these no nodes is a is
a Quantum repeater and between them
you've got a set of links right it's
actually a collection of networks it's a
network of networks that's what we mean
when we say inter Network in fact right
so you'll have different sorts of
Concepts you'll have Transit networks
you'll have some Network where your
request originates you'll have some
Network where it actually
terminates um and in particular since
what we're doing what we're talking
about is recursion in networks each of
these individual nodes here can in fact
represent a a network itself so inside
of that at the higher level you you when
you are planning your requests and
controlling your overall uh interaction
throughout the system you can treat an
entire network as a single node in the
system and that's where you get your
scalability so this was work that uh
Claire and uh a friend of mine named Joe
touch who's at USC isi the three of of
us did uh together about a year and a
half ago and appeared last year um if
you're if I'm boring you you can just
download the paper and take a look at
that while while we're talking instead
of listening to me
um let's see and Joe's background is
actually he's classical networking guy
as well and he's actually the guy who
came up with classical recursive
networks some which I'll talk about a
little bit
later so uh overall
my group we call the group Aqua which
stands for advancing Quantum
architecture and we work more or less in
five areas the overall Paradigm of what
we're working on is distributed Quantum
computation because I I believe that
systems individual systems are not going
to scale to the levels that that we
really want in order to actually
solve what you would call I suppose
commercially relevant problems so we're
interested in uh the the design of these
large scale distributed systems that in
includes things like we've actually done
some design of individual devices which
I talked a little bit about informally
the other day some of these are like
nanophotonic devices and things like
that um a lot of this work is done in
collaboration with guys at
Stanford done work on workloads and by
this I mean taking applications and
figuring out how well they will run on a
given architecture as opposed to
actually defining or creating new
Quantum algorithms themselves principles
meaning things
like um understanding how the principle
of locality from classical systems
actually applies to Quantum systems um
designing things like the quantum
multicomputer designing layered
architectures so applying what we
classical Architects think of as
standard engineering practice figuring
out how that's going to affect the
overall architecture of quantum systems
and finally some software tools and
you'll see a little bit about some of
those over the course of the
day-to-day so by the way let's see so
we're scheduled on the the schedule's
written till noon what time do you
actually want me to stop
um I'm not sure how
long should have asked this before we
started
but all right so
um let's see networks right so what are
quantum networks actually useful for um
and by the way you know feel free to
make this interactive feel free to
interrupt me and ask questions I
actually like to make a talk interactive
um so what are quantum networks and what
do we need them for well so the the
first sort of thing that obviously comes
to mind is we're going to do distributed
numerical computation uh and here you're
talking basically about more
computational power and sheer scale that
comes from from actually combining
systems and this was more or less the
original arpanet vision of distributed
uh shared Computing
resources in this sense it's we're
talking about Quantum multicomputers
maybe distributed Quantum databases
things things like that and at this
level probably talking primarily about
Quantum system area networks and local
area networks rather than um wide area
networks although the focus of the real
focus of today's talk is really about
the larger scale
networks for wide area networks for
example one of the things that might
actually be done a form of what you
would call numerical computation is
um excuse me uh form of quantum
Byzantine agreement which which has been
developed in theory and in fact was uh
actually demonstrated experimentally a
few few years ago as well and the goal
of something like that is fewer to
accomplish a task in fewer rounds of
communication in the quantum sense than
can be done classically
okay overall we expect that there will
be a lot more numerical uses for Bell
pairs GHC States W States um and we
would like to see more development of
these sorts of things in uh in the
overall literature for these uses
distributed uses of things uh one thing
thing that's been talked about you guys
probably saw it um showed up in science
a few weeks ago was blind Quantum
computation this is a good experiment
the theory was developed several years
ago uh the exper experimentally it was
demonstrated um
recently uh using an optical system they
divided the system into a Quantum server
and a Quantum client and in the system
sense where this would fit in would be
this would be essentially a a Computing
platform from from our point of view
it's not a specific algorithm but it
does fit into the overall structure of
networks as we're uh talking about it
okay let's see uh oh and this by the way
this assumes measurement based Quantum
Computing as a model that's built fairly
deeply into the concept of uh line
Quantum computation survey says
unmeasured quantity what's that it's an
unmeasured quantity the room next to us
is free ours won't talk to us let's
assume we're okay okay
let's
see so the all the flip side of the coin
those first couple things I talked about
was distributed numerical Quantum
computation the other side of the
equation is actually using Quantum
effects when you can build distributed
Quantum States for executing tasks that
you know you wouldn't necessarily
consider to be computational tasks but
that
come building in effect things like
sensor networks quantum or networks or
the like would would qualify in this
area um Quantum key distribution would
certainly qualify in in in this sense
because effectively what you're doing is
you're actually measuring the presence
or absence of a an EES dropper in that
sense and Sh nagama who's sitting in the
back uh his bachelor's thesis was
actually figuring out how to take
the um Keys generated by Quantum key
devices and integrate those into the use
of IPC for actually keying an IPC tunnel
so following on from the kind of work
that was done by the BBN guys including
uh chip Elliot and they sort of hacked
the protocol we decided we wanted a a
slightly more engineered protocol and
we've written an internet draft for this
we haven't gotten it to RFC status yet
but that would be one example another
one that came out last year which uh I
was really thrilled with was um Daniel
godsman showed how you can take um
distributed Bell Pairs and use those to
improve the Precision of measurement of
optical telescopes so doing effectively
interferometry where where your
reference standard is Bell pairs rather
than some sort of uh distributed
classical signal in that
sense um
truthfully this is this is a fabulous
thing uh I think it's a really wonderful
thought experiment and I actually talked
to Daniel about it and in order to pull
this off you're probably going to need a
minimum of 10 to the 9th Bell pairs per
per second maybe 10 to the 10 or 10 to
the 11 Bell pairs per second and the
networks we're talking about here right
the experimentalists are going in five
years we might get to one Hertz right so
we're
still a couple of orders of magnitude
away from actually pulling this off yet
but uh as sort of a goal is a good place
to go I think and one idea that I had um
a number of years ago but we haven't
actually pursued yet um actually the uh
in the eastern part of this state
whichever way East is um there's the uh
ligo the the uh gravity wave Observatory
could
we could those guys use it if we created
a network that that generated
entanglement between Washington and
Louisiana where the other Observatory is
could they use that to improve either
the resolution or sensitivity of their
of their uh detector um talked to Gerard
Milburn about this a little bit he's
like yeah you know that seems feasible
seems like something we could do but
nobody's actually sat down and done the
work yet um the reason this came up was
because in in fact those guys use
already they already have implemented
and in production non-classical states
of light in their detectors they use
form of State called a a squeezed
Quantum State um and I don't know that
anybody has yet figured out how how to
go between entanglement and squeezed
States but you know the guy who would
probably know would be a c for AEL
University of Tokyo anyway speculative
views okay
so um preview of what I'm going to going
to talk about or sort of the results
here I want to emphasize that Quantum
networking is distributed Quantum
computation and we think of a network we
really think of transmitting data from
one place to another and and as sort of
a passive activity but in fact for
Quantum networking this is not just
forwarding of data it uh the the
creation process of creating these
distributed States is in fact a
distributed Quantum computation itself
and I really want to emphasize that the
classical principles for how we design
classical networks um my sort
of way of working my my approach to to
solving problems is to figure out what
known
classical engineering principles we can
we can apply to the quantum systems
figuring out how things change in that
sense and we've been actually pleased to
see that that largely the classical
networking princip
apply we'll go through that in some of
the detail in a minute that includes
things like layering and multiplexing
Resource Management finite State machine
based design of the protocols all all
the usual approaches to things now this
one comes from from our collaborator Joe
touch Joe believes very very strongly
that recursion is a fundamental property
of networks uh it's not something that's
sort of tacked on it's a it's
fundamental to the behavior of the
networks themselves this is particularly
valuable for inter networking between
networks it's part of how you actually
get to scale in large scale
systems uh when I saw Joe's work on this
I realized that it applied very well to
what we want to do in designing Quantum
networks and so we've adopted the
concept pretty much
wholesale so outline what we're talk
about
today not sure if I really need to go
through the first part talking about
networking what's so hard of it parts of
this talk were engineered for Quantum
folks let's see we've got one hardcore
Quantum guy here I don't know about
you everybody else here's pro has has
strong background in systems right so
we're actually probably pretty much okay
in that sense talk very briefly about
four types of quantum repeaters Quantum
repeater network architectures and um
then go in particular into the results I
really want to show which are about uh
routing and multiplexing in networks and
then the discussion of the of the uh
recursive uh actual quantum network
architecture so networking what's so
hard about it we can sort of skimmed
through this part of the stuff I think
um naming resource management
heterogenity and both technology and
resources and operations this is one
that would never even occur to to the
physicist like well you know Microsoft
owns one network Google owns another
Network layer 3 owns another network
cable and wireless owns another Network
and they don't really want to talk to
each other more they don't want to tell
each other more than they have to in
particular about the internals of their
Network right so we need a system that's
actually going to accommodate those
sorts of things um dealing with
out-of-date information is of course a
big deal in networks and sheer scale
okay
so naming what is it that actually has
to be named in a in a network well nodes
networks processes users memory location
the request itself is is a particular
issue in Quantum networks that differs
from from classical networks and you'll
see why in a few minutes uh and things
like the scope of the name also matter
the semantics of a name can vary in in
types of networks and that means that
you're going to have to have some sort
of resolution mechanism as well that
translates from one Nam space to another
Nam space something like r or DNS would
be two examples of the Nam
space Resource Management avoiding over
commitment of your
resources uh something we all want to
achieve in classical networks it's going
to be different in Quantum networks in
some ways but we want to do that while
making sure that the overall network is
in fact efficient we need to balance the
fairness while minimizing the average
weight and maximizing the throughput of
the uh system right for competing
requests in a
network enforcing realtime communication
is actually difficult without some sort
of hard reservation mechanism meaning
Circ switch in serve as opposed to diff
serve um something something like that
and in Quantum networks because the
quantum information itself is so fragile
in fact that real-time component
actually figures pretty strongly into
the overall
system
heterogenity physical technology of
course bandwidth pulse rate quality of
the channel everything else all varies
Um this can be also whether it's single
pulses or strong laser pulses that
you're actually using as your phys
phical mechanism for actually doing your
your uh entanglement protocol there as
well heterogenity and your architecture
whether it's your dealing with packets
or uh circuit switching what have you
resource and network conditions your
length length your buffer memory all
that sort of stuff varies management and
operations and autonomy which goes back
to what I said about Google Microsoft
cable and wireless everybody right they
want to have autonomous operational
control over their entire
network dealing with out ofate
information Dynamic State connection
Dynamic Network State topology of the
network itself which links are up and
which ones are down right you don't want
to track the entire thing that sort of
stuff sheer scale billions of nodes
millions of
networks um individual nodes can't and
shouldn't track the entire state of the
entire network it's just not feasible
for something that's on the scale of the
internet the way we generally solve this
in classical networks is by applying a
form of higher Ary you the thing that's
sort of most obvious in that sense is
the difference between the the internal
Gateway protocol and the external
Gateway protocol at the level of the
global bgp the the Border Gateway
protocol for this uh internally um or
across the entire internet and the
challenge in doing this is maintaining
efficiency and robustness in the overall
system and Joe would argue that that the
right approach to doing this is actually
applying recursion at the system as a
whole because in fact what we have seen
the uh the arpanet was originally one
network and then it went to two layers
and then you could argue that it's
effectively three layers now you've got
the global bgp layer of interconnections
of autonomous systems beneath that you
have indiv individual organizational
wide area networks and then underneath
that you've got a set of local area
networks if we apply the same set of
engineering principles at each of these
layers we can build a a strong recursive
architecture which shares a lot of
knowledge and uh engineering effort so
we don't have to reimplement things
separately at each
layer okay that's everything about
classical networking but you guys all
knew
that the four types of quantum repeater
architectures I'm not going to go into
the details of of each of these types um
you can get these from the uh from the
papers of course purify and swap
architecture was originated by Wolf Gang
dur and and uh Hans Bal and other is
going back to about
1998 um various people have done lots of
contributions to this the uh the group
that I have worked with thus lad Bill
Monroe Kai namoto have done their share
of uh of work on this um others include
let's see um the the group of Misha
Lucan at Harvard would would be very
strong both experimentally and
theoretically on a lot of this work
there are some parts of their work that
I that I really think are are excellent
on other parts where I'm I'm not sure
that that that their
uh their conclusions are justified by
the data that's presented in some cases
so you know good things and bad things
about it um CSS encoded systems where
you're literally instead of doing
purification which is very simple form
of eror Correction doing fullscale
Quantum eror correcting codes on top of
the uh the physical entanglement
mechanism leang Jang uh who at the time
was a student of Misha lukans at Harvard
and is now postto talking at Caltech has
done some good work on that U Bill and
Kai and I are co-authors on on on that
particular paper of Leong's let's see
surface code Quantum computation so
Austin Fowler whom we all know as as the
uh primary Apostle of um surface code
the man who's figuring out how to make
it all work realized at some point that
that that this could actually be applied
to communication systems as well it
could be applied to repeater
architecture as well as to actual
computational architecture and again
Bill and Kai and our co-authors on on
this as Austin developed this out into a
repeater architecture these
architectures have interesting
differences
in how synchronous communication is
required across the across the entire uh
Network architecture which has a big
impact on your overall Behavior your
system and the last one would be the
Quasi async system of Bill Monroe which
he published in nature photonics a
couple of years ago and um I can't claim
I wasn't involved in in that one but
it's there are some very good very
interesting ideas in that one overall so
let's see what does the
word
um that's my term for this you can
go bill claims the the entire
architecture is fully asynchronous and I
don't think I really 100% believe that
assertion that's pretty much all the
Quasi means um you'll see in in in the
behavior of a lot of the repeater
networks there are a lot of cases where
for example when you're transmitting a
Quantum pulse you send it across the
fiber and then you have to wait until
you get a response back to whether or
not that that pulse actually arrived at
the far end before you can do something
with it so that would be synchronous
Behavior Bill claims that that with with
this new architecture he can do an awful
lot of stuff where he sends sends the
pulses and then each node can can
operate entirely asynchronously and
entirely autonomously with the behavior
of it there are a couple of places in it
where it
remains more or less
um rather than truly asynchronous
self-locked might actually be a a better
better term for it because the the the
uh the extra nodes in the system
essentially receive information from
from their neighbors but they don't get
to operate totally autonomously and
totally asynchronously there are places
where still round trip latencies wind up
showing up but it's roundtrip latencies
over a single link rather than end to
end and so the individual notes then get
to behave more differently in that sense
so that that's a very crude explanation
of it and Bill would certainly take um
anything I said about it ofal pardon say
that again it's kind of local
synchronization but not Global right in
that sense Link Link level link so
single hop level sorts of
stuff so most of what I'm actually
talking about most of the work we've
actually done in terms of simulation is
actually on the purify and swap form of
uh Quantum repeaters so that's actually
mostly what I'm going to talk about
today and what they need is a little bit
of quantum communication Quantum memory
local Quantum Gates well pretty much
this is true for pretty much all
repeater architectures lots of
decision-making both local and
distributed and lots of classical
communication we'll see how this sort of
all comes out oh so I should I should
probably say the differences between
these one of the key differences the
original purify and swap architectures
were developed assuming very small
numbers of Q bits in each repeater node
like the the uh the Harvard Gang has has
defined an approach for this that works
with two cubits in a repeater
node and they want to do this literally
with two physical cubits you can't run
error correction on two physical cubits
so the purify and swap stuff at that
level looks much less resource intensive
you know by orders of magnitude the
problem of course is that because it
requires synchronous communication now
you have to have long lifetime memories
and that that gets to be a very
difficult problem so if you then want to
turn around and what you would really
like to do is take each of those Q bits
after it arrives at the repeater node
upcode that into a large encoded state
so you can keep it for for the tens or
hundreds of milliseconds it's going to
take for for your roundtrip messaging
and then code it back down doing all of
that analysis and figuring out all of
the resources involved in this and the
execution time for everything and the
error probabilities for
everything overall is a big engineering
problem and although we have ideas
nobody's really done done a an analysis
that's really complete at that level
across all of it for really any of these
architectures at the level we would like
to see It ultimately um but it means
that you know so this one looks like it
takes tens of cubits per this looks like
it takes a handful of cubits per
repeater this one looks like it takes
tens this one looks like it takes
hundreds um bills it's it's not entirely
clear but but it should be a small
number
um but by the time you apply enough
error correction enough of everything
else that's going on the resource
analysis I think we've done the first
level analysis but we really need to go
the next level and make it much more
detailed as a as a
community um let's see let me show you
just just to sort of set the idea here
this is one network Link Technology
again developed by uh Bill Monroe and
Koto and Tim Spiller um Bill and uh and
Tim were at HP labs in Bristol at the
time Ka in Japan uh the CU buus
technology for for this and what you do
with this one is rather than sending
single photons you use actually a
moderately strong laser pulse which you
put into a a wave guide of some sort
which is coupled to a cubit at one end
and at the other so the distance here
might be millimeters it's effectively
what we were using in the distributed
architecture I talked about the other
day it might be kilometers but uh the
loss the loss in this channel is still
limited to a fewb which is which is a a
problem in terms of
implementation what this does is
it um effectively measures the parity of
these two cubits and what you get out as
a result when you measure it is in
effect the uh the parity of the two
cubits but with a lot of noise and so
you still need you get relatively low
Fidelity out of this when you come out
so simulations of this are in
uh fetus's paper in uh in uh new Journal
of physics and the original idea was in
Bill and Company's paper in the new
Journal of physics and this is also what
we have used in a lot of our own
simulations following on from
it see so uh just showing you again uh
what you get out of this is effectively
this entangled State here at the end
okay now entanglement swapping have you
guys seen entanglement swapping
before entanglement swapping is using
teleportation to lengthen the distance
of your entanglement so we got three
stations in the diagram here you know
each of these arrows represents a a qbit
so you run your single hop protocol to
create Bell pairs between station zero
and one and between station one and two
and then you run what's called
entanglement
swapping uh using what's called Bell
State measurement between the two of
these you measure which of the which of
the Bell States you think that pair of
Cubit is is in the result of that is uh
you lose your local entanglement and
you're left with long distance
entanglement problem the results of this
Bell State measurement actually have to
be communicated into the opposite ends
so this is where this is why you don't
violate relativity when you're actually
doing this
okay bigger problem Fidelity decreases
when you do this and so that means that
after you've done it so you start with
reasonable Fidelity entanglement after
you do this you're going to have lower
Fidelity that might be okay over two
hops it's going to be a problem if
you're talking about a thousand
hops this is the
nested purify and swap architecture that
was designed originally by dur and Bal
um if you go back and you read those
those uh original papers as the systems
architect it becomes a little bit hard
to tease apart where the entanglement
swapping is and where the purification
layer is in the overall system they've
got it essentially as one integrated
sort of a system the protocols are sort
of bound
together but what you do in this nested
approach if you've got four hops you do
entanglement swapping between uh you
know at station one which connects zero
and two and between and at station three
which connects two and four and then you
repeat you wind up freeing those cubits
in the middle and you end up with the
longer end in distance um much of the
original analysis was done assuming a
power of two number of hops this
approach obviously work works better
when you've got 4 8 16 10 24
hops so
purification we'll start with two
unentangled
pairs one so this is one unentangled
pair you held between station Z and two
and and another one held between 0 and
two perform some local operations at
each end between these two a local
operation basically amounts to a a c
notot followed by a a measurement you
measure out
two of these Cube bits here you get some
classical results if it all works what
you're left with the pair you're left
with has higher
Fidelity but again your results have to
be communicated and the usual protocol
means means you need actually two-way
communication or two oneway messages
actually okay so
uh that's sort of the basic idea those
are the the the real Concepts you need
to understand though
uh I looked at this and said well what
you need is you really need a protocol
stack you really need to understand how
this overall thing fits together so we
designed this uh physical entanglement
uh layer at the bottom above that your
direct message is saying whether or not
your entanglement message your
entanglement operations actually worked
entanglement control then above that
purification control and entanglement
swapping uh control so interestingly
these wind up being applied recursively
over one hop two hops four hops eight
hops which is why we think the one of
the the key reasons why we think the
recursive Network architecture actually
works well for this and then at the top
you'll have some sort of application
protocol which might be your your uh
Quantum key distribution or whatever it
is okay now
interestingly uh so this is done at the
distance one both of these are only over
a single physical hop these parts oops
see this part is repeated at different
distances and then again you'll need
some stuff end to end out of this entire
stack the only part that's Quantum is
this layer here at the
bottom everything else is classical
messages which means that everything
else is
messaging and distributed computation
the kinds of things that the people in
this room are experts in rather than the
the experimental physicists who are
trying to actually Implement some of
this stuff so that's sort of where you
know the division of work would be in
terms of a a community okay
let's see for hop stuff I think you see
probably how this uh interacts you'll
wind up with purification control and in
tanglement Swap and control h happening
over one hop and over two hops as well
as uh end to end over the course of
this um that's all at the relatively
abstract
level so let's look at this where you've
got multiple cubits involved in the the
system and you'll start to see how the
the complexity of the system actually
grows as you're doing this you're
sending a bunch of pulses you'll wind up
with some of your cubits entangled and
some of them not as you're doing this
between the various stations and then uh
what you're going to do you have to pick
out pairs of these and run your
purification protocol one of the things
one of the places where you have to be
careful in designing the overall system
is this guy and this guy have to make
the same decision about what pairs
they're going to
purify if he picks
one and two up here and he instead picks
up one and five and your purification
operation is not going to work and
you're going to have a a real problem in
your overall distributed system so you
have now there are different ways you
can achieve that you can you
can you need to analyze the set of
information that's available at each
station and make sure that that either
they can independently make the same
decision or if not that they are going
to communicate and and um share
information enough information to make
that decision
okay uh after you do the purification of
course you're left with uh fewer of the
actual entangled
pairs
now uh same sort of thing going on up
there we get a few entangled pairs in
this case the color we went from yellow
which is sort of an intermediate um
Fidelity pair to Green being a higher
Fidelity Bell pair and now here in the
middle green is good enough we said for
doing entanglement swapping we'll do the
entanglement swapping there and you get
the uh the longer distance stuff there
again you have to have enough
information to make the correct
decisions everywhere
right this station two in the middle
knows enough about these Bell pairs to
make a good decision here but one and
three don't know anything about what's
going on at two until two tells them
they don't know what decisions two has
made and in particular one probably
doesn't know anything about the
connection between two and three right
that's an important sort of information
hiding principle involved
there and that's pretty much it on the
basic operation so that's sort of all
background that's
uh with the exception of the protocol
stack itself that's all work that that
everybody else has done um let's see so
let me show you some of our actual
results this was some of this was the
bachelor's thesis of uh one of my
students takikos who's now um finishing
his master's degree at the University of
Tokyo and uh L opio who was doing his
master's degree at at to I but was
working with
me routing you guys know
this uh we want to create entanglement
between a and b in this
network how do you decide how to get
from A to B what would you use to decide
down how to get on how you're going to
get from A to
B yeah sure path
selection how about dyra shortest path
first the problem is
in a quantum network we don't know what
the cost metric is we don't know how to
actually figure out what that best path
is
okay let's see for Hop Network
here circle is pretty good X is a pretty
poor Network and triangle is sort of an
intermediate length the cost for this
path would be some function of those
link costes right now what is that in
class classical dyra the cost would just
be the sum of those individual
lengths with Quantum version we don't
actually know sort of a priori what the
right way is to combine these in order
to get some some reasonable cost for the
overall
path
okay so let's look at the link
cost these are a set of simulations this
was of QBs interconnections
over uh I think these were over 10 km
but with some additional loss thrown in
so the x-axis here is uh DB loss in your
channel from from one end to the other
and the vertical axis here is then uh
throughput of bell pairs purified to a
particular Fidelity so in this case all
of these Bell pairs have been purified
to a Fidelity of 0.98 and once that's
done then they're delivered and they're
counted as part of our throughput here
so you can see as loss increases the
blue line here your uh
throughput is going to decline and in
fact it seems to decline in a stairstep
fashion this is a result of the number
of rounds of uh purification you wind up
doing so this would be one round of
purification two rounds of purification
three rounds of purification four give
or take roughly so the blue curve here
is a the throughput and you know this is
a couple of hundred belt pairs per
second the green curve here is the
number of measurement operations done in
the network as a whole or well so this
is single hop stuff so this is at at the
uh the two ends of of our single hop um
the red line is the number of pulses you
put into the fiber So In classical
networks you particularly if it's like
an Ethernet or if it's uh it's like an
OSF Network or something
um throughput is usually used as uh your
inverse metric so one over throughput is
the cost for actually using a link in uh
OSF
uh me the protocol is independent of
that but that's that's the most common
definition uh that's used and that was
uh defined by Fred Baker who's CH past
chair of the iatf okay so that sounds
good right one gigabit per second you
know that's one bit every nanc sounds
good we can't use a direct approach like
that in the quantum networks because we
don't know AR priori what what the
Fidelity of the link is going to be
whether it arrives or not once it gets
there whether or not it's used ful so in
fact we have to to sort of move up a
level and find a uh yeah sure question
so I have a stupid question no stupid
questions I'm I there are no stupid
questions in my world so in in in uh
traditional communication if I need to
uh communicate a message to you now I
need some BWI now right whereas isn't it
true that in Quantum I can say okay I
will need sometime today I will need to
communicate a message I can actually
buy the BWI pay for the bandwidths now
and communicate it later without without
paying at the time of really
communicating right so so that mean that
some of the um um measurement that we do
especially for throughput are kind of
different because if I when when we're
talking about traditional I know that
you know I'm running my application now
if I don't get uh you know um um this
amount of traffic within a second
someone is going to be waiting but it's
not so much true in in this case right
you absolutely correct and in fact one
of the things that comes up particularly
as you talk about scaling up the
networks is figuring out how to map
operations on the network to a
particular request because what you're
what you're doing in this kind of
quantum network is you're creating very
generic end to-end States right so I
want to create one between a I'm going
to need 100 Bell pairs between Seattle
and LA
right but the link
between Portland and and San Francisco
all it's doing is creating Bell Pairs
and it doesn't know whether those are to
be assigned to my connection between
Seattle and LA or your connection
between Vancouver and St Louis abiso
it's a completely different Marketplace
because it makes s that the you know the
the the hubs in the middle they will be
creating they they will be creating enti
month all the time and over a single
link that's really easy it's really
obvious that the sinks ought to just run
flat that the individual links ought to
run flat out they ought to be trying to
create entanglement all the time the
question comes in for things like the
entanglement swapping it's like well you
know now do I connect point A to point C
or do I connect point A to point D which
one's the better thing for me to be
doing right
now so yeah absolutely you're you're
100% correct and that's the kind of
problem I want to solve and if you want
to work on it great we'll work together
but there's also there's an additional
factor in the quum case that you can't
can't have these things hanging around
waiting cuz as soon as you stick M
States
and so what is the time for
um it depends it depends on how much on
what type of me youve got so if it's
a um error correction is cost
complim so you wouldn't want to pay now
get 10 Bell Pairs and use them in an
hour because keeping them at a high
vality for an hour will cost you lot
yeah so the service providers will
probably charge you to store those
cubits in the meantime right is it is it
is it something that um due to the
technology that we have now or is it uh
uh TR to believe that this is the
reality this is reality because this is
why so the reason why qu mechanics
buil is theant system will interact
anything that Poss can any possible
opportunity Quantum memory is stopping
them doing what they want and that is
always going to be
difficult but yeah it's
so you know we used to batch email via
uucp and uset and everything else in the
middle of the night because that was a
whole that was when the networks weren't
being used right in this Marketplace so
maybe I'll I'll ask for 100 pairs to be
to be ready by 6:00 a.m. or something
right and but then if you don't use them
until noon you got to pay somebody to
store them until noon
right that's definitely the kind of
thing we want to evaluate right so this
still is one this is over single link
right what we're looking for here is a
metric for our link cost um so it looks
like in this case both for a single hop
for over this the number of pulses and
the number of measurements both look to
be sort of reasonable metrics compared
to this they sort of go up as as
throughput goes down we'll see though
that that one of these is actually winds
up being a slightly better uh metric um
for these for the purposes of these
simulations we picked out four points on
this curve that were just chosen
arbitrarily we said in our Network there
are four types of links there four Links
of four different qualities that's where
they
are
okay first set of
results the uh grade bars are a
throughput well let's see so the x-axis
here this is a set of paths that we
actually simulated and what you're
looking at here um for example square
triangle triangle triangle triangle
which is here somewhere that would be uh
a path with one excellent link and three
good links in it right so this is the
set of things we did and then across
this they are ordered according to
throughput throughput is the uh the uh
the total distance here and
or the total height there and then the
two measures of work that we use the
number of pulses in the channels and the
number of measurement operations this is
across the entire path in that sense and
again sort of qualitatively you can see
that that there's a pretty good inverse
correlation between between the
two a little more
detail these are for um 40 different
paths the same 40 paths that are in this
diagram here um but this for these cover
distances ranging from 1 to nine hop
with different combinations of uh total
uh
um different combinations of uh high and
low quality paths in this and the x-axis
in this case is path cost calculated
using
the
um path cost
using number of measurements here as
your as your link cost for each of those
individual costs and then just summing
those get our path cost here so uh this
is inverted so low cost paths here high
cost paths there and you can see that as
the uh as the cost increases that
throughput
declines the different colors of marker
here um these with the red X's are all
paths that contained one poor Link in
the in the overall system the the green
ones had uh were Paths of different
lengths that were all the best quality
uh paths and you can see this sort of a
relationship here they tend to
group according to the bottleneck link
which in terms of throughput is the way
a classical Network actually uh behaves
so in terms of throughput we're seeing
something that looks a great deal like
what we would expect in classical
systems that's
reassuring on this side over here
comparing the total cost again the same
set of things um number of measurements
here on this line and total number of
pulses in the uh in the green triangle
angles and you can see just from looking
at this that in fact the uh the the
measurements are actually going to be a
more consistent overall um measure of
your total cost they tend to to Hue more
closely to to an actual line than the
green ones do and statistics on that are
in the
paper so got strong correlation between
the pathwork there those were for
different lengths of uh paths from one
to nine hops this is all of the possible
four hop paths you know all 256 of them
using our four um data types and again
you can see here really clearly you can
see the the that the throughputs
definitely determined by the bottleneck
link and you got
really here it's even more clear that
that the the measurement number as
opposed to the number of pulses is the
right metric for uh or link
cost uh this in particular and takes
into account the fact that
um measurements are used for
Bell State measurement and for the
actual entanglement swapping as well as
for the
purification which the uh the number of
pulses can't really take into account
all right so results of this chunk of
work this was the first work to really
quantitatively evaluate the behavior of
heterogeneous paths pretty much
everybody else sort said yeah you know
sooner or later we'll have to do that
but they all assumed homogeneous stuff
in their networks uh and as far as I'm
aware we're the first to actually
consider path ction in topologically
complex networks and how you would
choose a an appropriate path for
something there counting the number of
measurement operations winds up being a
good metric for the total cost to the
network to everybody in the network as a
whole to create this and so that winds
up being something that's well worth
evaluating and the throughput of that
individual link makes a good cost metric
for for the for the uh for the link um
and uh the additive path cost actually
turns out to work pretty well so summary
of that Quantum dyra seem to work pretty
well and I'm sorry uh Burton isn't here
because he actually said Quantum dyra
the other day when we were talking about
that too bad all right next chunk of
work I'll show you this one we may not
actually really get into the uh
recursive stuff unless you guys want to
stay until 12:30 or
something let's do the uh Resource
Management real
quick remember this is some sort of
distributed computation and this fragile
memory means we've got a real problem
here right so does this require some
sort of circuit switching this is
another sort of uh resource evaluation
system resource evaluation of the kinds
of work that that I like to do in this
multiplexing scheme you guys uh know
this let's say we've got we got a
dumbbell Network here we want one flow
to go from A to B and another flow to go
from C to d right we can do this using
um circuit switching which means you're
going to be everybody else is going to
have to wait uh we can do it using time
division multiplexing where you just
sort of flip back and forth between the
to for a
while or we can do buffer space
Multiplex you can take half of the
memory at at the intermediate nodes and
say well we'll dedicate this to this one
and again it's going to require some
sort of reservation mechanism to
actually do
this this is in fact the network that we
uh simulated for for this um and what
you see from this
is we actually investigated mechanisms
where we Dynam ically adjusted the
target Fidelity for each of these
individual links so most most of these
simulations so far we said we'll only
use a Bell pair after we've purified it
to a Fidelity of 0.98 which means over
every distance we applied the same kind
of thing in this case we varied this on
the middle because the middle is the
bottleneck link right well so maybe we
should find a way to sort of minimize
the use of that at the expense of making
AE C e BF and and DF work harder because
in something like the circuit switch
scenario or or even the time division
multiplexing those links are going to
wind up being idle a bigger fraction of
the time and we might as well take
advantage of what they've got so in fact
what we did find in the process of doing
this was that if you Multiplex this
correctly you'll wind up with
substantially better overall system
throughput for for multiple
connections let's see larger Networks
um even the dumbbell network is to the
best of my knowledge the most complex
topologically complex repeater network
anybody has bothered to to to simulate
even at that that simple level this one
more complex
Network um what we want to do is we've
got a half a dozen flows that are
running through this 1 two 3 four five I
guess running different places the
blue set of lines is one flow um the
oranges is another and part of what
we're looking at here is in this case
we've got some short flows and some
longer flows and one of the things we
want to know in the process of doing
this um is can the network be fair do
will short connections wind up um
driving the long connections out of
business depending on how you actually
do the multiplexing
scheme
um let's see what we found while doing
this is in uh
this would be Peak ideal throughput so
in this case we got so each of these
colors represents the the throughput of
the matching uh um diagram on this case
this is the entire network is dedicated
to just the
blue this is the entire network is
dedicated to just The Red Connection
which is also a a longdistance
connection here and uh the shorter ones
obviously you see more so this would be
if everybody could get the maximum
bandwidth they managed to achieve our
Network as a whole would achieve this
right that would be some sort of Ideal
case um when we take just the two pairs
each of these two pairs actually gets
greater than 90% of its own ideal
throughput so the degrad degradation to
one connection as a result of the
introduction of a second is less than
10% in this case and a couple of other
cases here as the total number of flows
you add in um increases of course the
the each one gets penal penalized sort
of more one of the things you can see
though is that
um even for some of the longer distance
ones in this case you can see here the
longer distance one succeeded in
retaining 77% of its throughput whereas
some of the shorter ones actually
actually suffered a little bit more of a
hit in their throughput which is
actually sort of a little bit of a
surprise counterintuitive
uh so let's see so how can we evaluate
this let's see so this was for time
division multiplexing here on on
those same sort of thing for statistical
multiplexing and in fact in this case we
actually got um better overall
throughput in the statistical
multiplexing case which is essentially
the behavior of the internet as opposed
to you know cell phone network so
statistical multiplexing in this case we
actually think works better and and
buffer space multiplexing this is the
case where the intermediate nodes sort
of split their memory out turned out to
not work quite as
well we actually did evaluate the
fairness of these using Jane's fairness
metric to see how how the the different
flows actually competed and we actually
found it somewhat to our surprise that
actually all three mechanisms retained
very good fairness in that sense so
we're actually pretty happy in that
sense and uh we think actually that the
statistical multiplexing gives the
overall all best system through but but
the biggest question is that that memory
lifetime issue that's one of the things
that needs continue uh needs continued
analysis X1
XD the X1 through
xn those are in this equation throughput
in Bell pairs per
second all right this part I'm going to
just going to flash through but I wanted
you all see sort of part of how we did
this you won't see a finite State
machine with State Transitions and and
and triggered sorts of stuff in in the
work by the physicist but it's the way I
like to design protocols so different
layers of this
stuff all right so that's sort of
everything about um Quantum dyra and
about multiplexing any questions on on
those two
topics let's do about 10 minutes on the
recursive stuff and then uh then we'll
uh call it then how about that that's
unreasonable let's
see okay thanks you can get the
recursive stuff by by looking at the
paper or the video or the video or the
video yes um so Joe like I said insists
that fundamental is a that recursion is
a fundamental Network property it's not
just some sort of engineering artifact
for for the way we build things U it
unifies the overall uh architecture of
the system and provides new way to go
about doing tunneling and overlay
networks and multi-layer networks all of
all sorts of things let's see um I'm
just going to flip through this we'll
skip some of this stuff and go straight
to the quantum
parts so the quantum
stuff here's our recursive Network the
diagram that I showed you at the
beginning again we've got Transit
networks recursive networks individual
sorts of uh things involved here um
let's say in this case what we're trying
to do is we're trying to create an
untangled pair between a couple of these
nodes uh or actually each of these pink
nodes would be in what we're trying to
create as a one large and Tangled State
between those uh end nodes of the system
okay let's see and for a simpler example
we we'll look at just these half a dozen
nodes uh here uh we're going to start
with our reest that originates here and
what we're asking for is entanglement
between node 11 node 5 5 and node 77 in
in this overall architecture here now
the way you would do
this is uh so we're looking we're
looking for a uh the a state that would
result from a circuit like this where
the the circles are controll phase
control Z
gate we want to create this over a
distributed system right now the
question is how you going to go about
doing it one way to do it would be to
create this 3 cubit State all of it here
at the the node node 11 you know this is
the guy who who's essentially
controlling your distributed application
you can create them all here and then
teleport two of the cubits from from
from where you are to to the far ends of
the network over top of uh belt pairs is
that the most efficient way to actually
do the overall system well you know it
might actually be better if we started
with it in the middle and then spread it
out right um which of these is more
efficient in order to understand all of
this you have to have routing tables
available to each of these guys they
have to have some amount of
understanding of the overall system
right so here at note 11 it holds a
routing table that looks something like
this it knows how to get
to network 5 and how to get to network 7
out of this via other networks in in the
system sort of a relatively standard uh
routing table sort of approach um the
guy in the middle here is going to have
a somewhat different routing table of
course neither one of them would
understand the every n node in the
entire network
right so what we're going to do is we're
actually going to rewrite this request
so we'll start with this here's our
request so we want to have um node 11
node 55 and node 77 all in this
entangled State and the guy who creates
this request is going to say when I'm
communicating with you about this
request we'll use the address 1000 to
refer to to the the Q bit you this is
effectively the memory address virtual
memory address for for the Q bit that's
involved in this state okay so we're
going to take this and we're actually
going to rewrite it into uh the set of
operations for doing this overall
original request well we can divide it
up into three teleportation operations
and each of those teleportation
operations can then get split out
into first the creation of a set of bell
Pairs and then the actual
uh
um teleport or
um combination operation here at the end
itself so we're going to have to have
this overall uh set of States
here so doing this why is this valuable
um this provides ideal support for
internetworking we think and uh this
will allow or support hierarchical
routing of op operations very smoothly
and it will unify these software
implementations across multiple levels
so in this case um the request that
you've got so this guy knows here in the
middle when he's doing this um I want to
teleport
from one cubit Network 5 address 2,000
Network 5 3000 we want to get that
to network to node 55 1000 as it's drawn
here in the uh in the original uh
Network diagram right so that's node 55
about here the original request from
node 11 knows the address and name of
these individual nodes but it doesn't
know the name the the names of in of
other individual nodes throughout the
entire network so it starts with a
generic request that says somebody here
in the middle connect me to
that
and that rewrite rule those rewrites can
happen in various places throughout the
network okay so let's see um what's
interesting about this it it essentially
unifies the distributed computation with
with transmission of data so the
teleportation
operations it's only we need to be able
to requ to request in order to make um
even just bellare creation work properly
we have to be able to request
purification which includes cot
operations and dependent operations or
conditional operations dependent on on
the outcomes of things like measurement
operations so we've already got cot
measurement and conditional operation
extending from there to a fully General
distributed computing mechanism is
actually a very small leap from there so
what we really want to do is we want to
just go ahead and do the extension of
that and create a unified distributed
mechanism which means that this guy at
the end can request of nodes in the
middle of the network or of networks in
the middle of the network work please
create this state for me and here's a
recipe for actually doing
it um too bad uh Alex left already
because here's the uh this diagram is
actually from Bill's paper on some of
the asynchronous stuff and this Gap here
this timing Gap here depends in part on
the uh the single hop latency in the
network and that's where some of the
Quasi asynchronous Behavior comes
through it this diagram is from Bill's
paper and what they said
was one way to create and good and and
Bell pairs is to start from the middle
of the network and then propagate them
out via teleportation until you've got
end to end okay it's a great in theory
the question is in a billion no network
how do you find the middle what's the
middle of of the internet right what's
the middle of a connection between here
in Tokyo
um we need uh approaches to doing that
right so here's your your network as a
whole where's the
metal uh all of this can be done
ultimately with one single software
module one of Joe's papers on on um
recursive networks actually includes the
pseudo code for doing essentially all of
networking as one as one recursive uh
function for doing this and basically
all it ever does is it can discard
forward to a neighbor deliver to an
upper layer buffer or transform a a
state so you have to have those set of
operations
available and that's pretty much it open
problems in networking well the biggest
problem is that the repeter hardware
doesn't really work
yet uh large scale networks have not
been really addressed by pretty much
anybody uh up until
now that entanglement swapping that I
was talking about connecting different
sections of the network that all
involves a lot of policy sort of
operations and we've done some
optimization to that there's still a
good deal more work that needs to be
done in larger scale
networks part of the driving reason
behind Bill's quaser sync stuff and
liang's work and um Austin's work is to
try to eliminate some of these roundtrip
Communications delays required in the
classical protocols particularly for
purification there are also one-way
purification protocols that are not as
efficient the goal of all of this is to
trade off things in the entire system
that are lowcost or essentially free in
order you we'll do more of that in order
to do less of this right it's those
kinds of engineering tradeoffs and the
single biggest one like Claire said is
really memory we want to avoid buffering
QQ bits as much as we possibly can and
that was really bills
driving reason for creating the the
Quasi async stuff and it's really good
now what I want to see is I want to see
that put into a more complete overall
endend Network architecture using
something like the uh the
qrna um there's still probably plenty of
other management mechanism error
management mechanisms we can investigate
and the resource management models as
well and ultimately hopefully
standardization so that we can build
this once rather than 100
times and thanks to the gang of
collaborators um there's a list of some
of the
papers and some nice photos of uh KO and
the the gang including our annual Beach
day that's the group let's see so Lucha
is the guy who did much of this uh
simulation work uh and Sao did the did
the quantum dyra work on that those are
the guys who did that they are and
showed the IPC that's Joe touch up there
with the with a recursive matro scadal
as part of his recursive networking
Stu some of our
friends uh there's fam and this is from
our beach day last summer including the
P the interested Burton so and that's
pretty much it don't forget
information's
physical that's it
thanks questions anything additional so
using these consum up you know there's
these from measurement L teques these
consumed up teleportation circuits long
distance consum up teleportation long
distance constant depth teleportation I
haven't seen so there's there's circuits
you can use that will do in constant
depth create a long distance
teleportation or long distance inang so
it seems like in who who did that I
haven't seen it
um um H visit a haror I have the paper
in my office I can show you
like 2009 um physicist Jake Taylor Jake
Taylor thank you yeah um Jake is really
did some of it but a lot of it was also
done in measurement only uh in the
measurement only Community I don't
recall having seen that particular
phrase but but assuming we're talking
about the same chunk of work yeah one
of that's like the penas paper or
something right what is it for the paper
from the proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences this is embedded in
the appendix of one of Jake's papers
that was on the archive but we're using
it for our um CL see the adder work that
um Paul found my inured last summer and
I did uh and we were using this constant
up tation ciruit there to do long
distance or I should say Conant death
fan out that would be analogous um and
that works so it seems in this work of
networking definely well was fan out
actually in particular I mentioned at
the beginning one of the things we would
like to see is an overall structure for
building and using belt Bears GHC States
W States so we want that would fit very
well into the overall recursive Network
architecture yeah so you can do that we
need a set of requests absolutely it
could be done in in within this
framework we have not simulated that as
as part of the specific work we've done
I said earlier that there were some
things about the work from that group I
was a little bit dubious about in
particular well I guess we're being
recorded bels anyway um but the the the
single biggest thing that I was dubious
about was was in one of liang's or one
of Jake's papers I think it's this this
panas paper um he was trying to
determine what the optimal link length
is for their particular architecture and
he test you know tested across a big
perameter space and came back and said
you know 20 km is the best for this but
I really think in that case that the
result wound up being driven by the
inang lement swapping architecture and
not not the link level parameters that
he thought he was evaluating so I think
I think the conclusion was was more or
less predetermined by the way the
simulation was set up rather than rather
than actually coming out of it so you
know the hardware architecture they have
done is is fine I don't think I buy all
of the systems statements that they made
about what the best way is to to do some
of the
stuff with with the constant de the
problem is there there are a whole Lo
way you can do distribution the problem
is getting itze
Fidelity you know if you do a constant
depth bur out um if you don't have any
way of purifying as you go you're going
to have to start incredibly good stud
yeah and as soon as you start sending
that through the network
gra so
there not
see at least the time
is yeah the time the time Dev is are of
actually getting it because you need
yeah yeah to use it at the
end it's not just get a cuz you could do
conent fan out get the whole load of um
things found out and then purify around
here then you've got purification
messages going from one end way to the
other yeah if you're doing this and
within an integrated system that that
whole classical messaging like if you're
wanting to get from one end of of of
your computer to the other or one end of
the chip to the other it's not a problem
right but again you know a lot of this
winds up being how much does each when
in a real distributed system how much
does each node know when and how do you
make how do you guarantee that they're
making consistent decisions um some of
this does fall out some of it you can
kind of Define a relatively simple
algorithm and say if if all the nodes do
exactly this then it'll work um in other
cases I don't think you can actually
eliminate some of the the the stuff yeah
so this is this is simulation of or
output from one run of our simulator and
you can see that it that it's building
over so this is one transmitter this is
the second node this is the third node
this is the fourth node and the fifth
node and you wind up with sort of
gradually building Fidelity over the
course of of these with a whole bunch of
this stuff and you can see that in a
system this complex making those those
decisions consistently and well is not
going to be trivial right so finally
here after all this has been running we
finally have a two hop link here now
this one's waiting on the appearance of
another two hop entangled pair so that
it can actually uh entangle there
somewhere the Lucho did these let me
show you real quick just the um this was
still using the uh the single chain
simulator that Thaddius and I wrote
several years ago more recently lucho's
work was um to
create a the actual Network simulator
that I showed you and uh here's what the
here's what it actually looks like when
it's running and this is actually built
off of uh omnet Plus+ which is a uh
standard freely available uh Network
simulator package so you know it's
designed for for doing Wireless
simulations and and um internet
simulations of various sorts and and
Lucho wrote up plugins for this so so
that we could actually run large scale
networks onto on the uh on top of omnet
using the simulation
protocol and you can see you know eor is
the student who recorded this for me you
can hear him clicking on his keyboard
it's a good thing he wasn't actually
talking to his girlfriend or something
while he was recording this
um but yeah so Thaddius is original
simulator that did the stuff that I
showed you earlier with the quantum
Dyess stuff includes lots of low-level
physical Sim uh uh simulation stuff
detecting what the right detector window
is you know how wide do you make these
sorts of things in order to optimize the
probability of detecting a high fidelity
State and all of that sort of
optimization of the qbus link it also
supports things you know some of the S
single Photon stuff like the the LC and
groups work um so it does the same sort
of thing um but then that simulator
couldn't do networking and and it's it
was in terms of adapting the meth
messaging and the protocols for p
purification and things like that wound
up being really brittle and so we
decided that the right thing to do was
to rewrite it in in a more networking
oriented simulator so this one does all
of the all of the the messaging sorts of
stuff we can support routing protocols
we can support in theory at least
different purification protocols and all
these other sorts of things it doesn't
yet have enough of the bottom level
physical parameter implementation in it
in in this simulator so we've still got
your
juston so I was thinking when you
mentioning the memory and topological
cues might be you know great memory but
if you can bu between aonic and a
topical you can store it yeah absolutely
one of the big questions is what's the
Fidelity of that operation transferring
from one to the other
right if it's less if you want to use
these for qkd you know so I said all of
these simulations were done to reach an
end to end Fidelity of 0.98 which wound
up also being useful as as the link
layer Fidelity that's good enough for
running something like qkd if you want
to do distributed computation Fidelity
of .98 is not going to be enough you're
going to need 49 5 9 9 or something of
Fidelity by by the time you get to this
if you want to run large scale
distributed computations um and you know
there are a few people who've been
investigating you know
moving cubits between physical
mechanisms between you know a uh know uh
an electron spin or or the nucleus you
know like like Luc
group and most of those you know the
Fidelity looks like it's going to be
pretty low at least for the foreseeable
future and if you want to say you know
if you're going to store for a long time
keep it and then say after we bring it
back out of the memory then we'll we'll
rerun error correction or we'll rerun
purification or something that's fine
but if you if you think you're going to
to do it all purification once and then
store it in the long-term memory and
leave it there and then use it right
right
afterwards then then that busing
protocol has to be extremely high
fidelity and that's going to be a
problem all right anything else
thanks